et donc c'est une annonce importante
c'est bizarre de lui faire un clin d'œil
de mie conscient attendez faut je le
vois de plus près
salut aujourd'hui on va se tenter une
analyse d'Emmanuel Macron quand il a été
face à Hugo décrypte alors plutôt une
analyse du langage non verbal plutôt une
analyse neutre j'essaie de pas être
anti-macron ou Macron et surtout c'est
important de le rappeler je ne vais pas
traiter le fond mais principalement la
forme du nom verbale du Para verbal des
fois des mots mais pas des idées je le
fais je le fais parce que je suis obligé
de le faire vous me demandez partout sur
Instagram sur Twitter et puis non j'ai
très envie de le faire comme toujours
une mise en garde avant de commencer si
vous utilisez des passages de ma vidéo
vous êtes obligé de garder cette mise en
garde sinon vous me faites gaffe
n'importe quoi l'analyse que je vais
faire ça vaut une analyse de comptoir
dans un PMU ça n'a pas de valeur
scientifique et ça n'a pas de valeur de
véracité un petit exercice de style
alors évidemment je vais essayer de
gommer la subjectivité je vais piocher
dans des outils qui sont parfois
vraiment de la pseudoscience genre de la
PNL la synergologie on en parle même pas
parce que vraiment il y a rien de ne
garder là-dedans bref exercice de style
un peu divertissant me faites pas dire
ce que j'ai pas dit maintenant on va
essayer d'analyser tout ça bonjour
monsieur le Président bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté cette interview merci de
prendre le temps aujourd'hui c'est votre
la première interview audiovisuelle
depuis un petit peu plus d'un mois
c'était pendant l'été aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux notre travail est
suivi par plusieurs millions de jeunes
et donc forcément on commence par la
mise en scène on commence par la mise en
scène parce que elle est pas faite au
hasard évidemment on voit Emmanuel
Macron cassis face à Hugo décrypte il y
a pas de vrais tables entre c'est pas un
bureau donc ils sont sur un pied
d'égalité Emmanuel Macron a fait tomber
la veste il en chemise mancelli mais tu
peux pas être en chemise comme ça donc
on va mettre la veste sur le dossier
comme ça derrière bien mise etc comme ça
ça montre que c'est un truc un petit peu
off en fait que tu parles librement tout
ça évidemment c'est c'est tout à fait
calculé alors je vais pas regarder les
1h45 que c'était un petit peu long en
fait pour le faire si on voulait sortir
la vidéo un petit peu rapidement il y a
quelqu'un chez moi au bureau qui
travaille avec nous qui a déjà isolé des
passages qui ont l'air intéressant
aujourd'hui on est un jour de rentrée on
va évidemment parler d'éducation mais
pas que on va parler de tout un tas de
sujets qui concerne notre génération des
sujets d'inégalités des sujets de
précarité on a le très classique
mouvement Corp
de faire dans le fond et dans la forme
et comme Emmanuel Macron lui envoie rien
c'est pour ça que à la fin il a ce petit
cette petite déglutition en disant voilà
si si ça vous va on va commencer parce
que il a il a le temps d'avoir quand
même un retour en face Emmanuel Macron
lui donne qu'à ce moment-là la santé le
bien-être de la population me semble et
je pense qu'on sera sûrement d'accord
là-dessus être un élément prioritaire
pour un chef d'État les chiffres
pourtant sont alarmants comment la
situation peut-elle être aussi grave
d'abord merci de commencer par ce sujet
je pense ne date pas j'aime bien ce
début il y en a qui mon spectacle j'ai
tout une partie sur le mentalisme
embrouillant où je prends comme exemple
de personnalités politiques et donc
quand ils veulent choisir leur mot juste
avant j'explique dans le show que ça
commence par toujours écouter vous-même
demandé si nananana je vous remercie
d'avoir posé la question c'est
exactement ce qui vient de faire avec
voilà tout d'abord voilà merci beaucoup
d'avoir posé la question alors c'est un
peu faussement empathique et en même
temps ça commence à préparer ces
éléments de réponse dans la tête pour se
faire un petit plan en général en
quelques points d'ailleurs si vous avez
pas remarqué la deuxième tournée de mon
spectacle la dernière tournée
d'archétype est annoncée je fais 45
villes elles apparaissent là devant vous
je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo
mais je vous mets les liens dans la
description si vous voulez me voir quand
je passe par chez vous on peut se voir à
la fin spectacle mentalisme humour
science ça dure deux heures voilà hop on
enlève les villes on continue en France
on est à un psychologue pour 15000
étudiants les universités c'est dix fois
moins que les recommandations
internationales sur le sujet alors le
deuxième problème qu'on a j'allais venir
c'est en effet qu'on n'a pas assez de
professionnels d'abord de psychiatrie
vient d'enlever sa montre vous souvenez
le une des dernières analyses qu'on
avait fait où il enlevait sa montre
d'ailleurs j'avais même pas vu que
c'était sa montre qu'il a enlevé je
comprenais pas ce qu'il faisait sous la
table à l'époque je l'avais vu après
j'ai l'impression qu'il m'a préparé un
petit tour de magie tu regardes toute
manière avec moi j'ai un lapin mais
attends mais il a descendu ses mains
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi j'ai pas
un plan là-dessus quand il parlait ça
montre elle tapait comme ça sur la table
ça engage que moi mais là il est en
train de troller tout le monde juste là
il a pas de table il va pas taper il
aurait plus de l'enlever avant s'il
avait envie d'être à l'aise avec la
version j'ai enlevé ma veste je trouve
ça inconcevable qu'il est pas conscience
qu'il est en train d'enlever sa montre
en live et que ça va faire parler je
sais pas si ça a fait parler d'ailleurs
ou pas mais pour moi c'est une ref et
c'est un gros coup de troll d'abord sur
la psychiatrie après haut-parleur
éventuellement des psychologues le
besoin il est pas dans 10 ans il est
maintenant comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire alors le
première chose si je reprends les choses
dans le bon ordre un diagnostic de te
comprendre comment cette situation se
crée et d'essayer de travailler sur la
prévention et elle se crée parce qu'il y
a du stress justement chez des jeunes
collégiens lycéens puis étudiant
parfois sur les questions écologiques si
vous suivez les analyses que j'ai pu
faire sur Mesnil Macron on récupère son
grand classique il commence par
bafouiller donc sa réponse est mal
construite dans sa tête et en plus c'est
une question qui est sûrement difficile
il y a pas de problème je traite pas
encore une fois le fond donc il en
revient au doigt magique
au doigts il y a un deux et trois et on
le voit assez net il commence par
bafouiller donc c'est que c'est piègeant
donc il va il va reprendre des petits
points comme ça ça lui permet de revenir
en arrière et pendant les numéros en
fait des choses qui sont juste de
l'observation de base donc antécédent et
qui ne résolvent pas la question qu'on
lui a posé ça lui permet après de
trouver des éléments de dire et aussi de
gagner du temps ça c'est une technique
pas propre à Emmanuel Macron mais à
toutes les personnalités politiques
c'est-à-dire que la réponse de quelqu'un
elle va s'en créer dans la mémoire de
travail qui a une durée de vie de 5
secondes donc plus la réponse est longue
plus on a oublié la précision de sa
question au départ donc il suffit de
répondre dans le même thème et même si
on a pas rapporté une réponse précise le
cerveau de ceux qui écoutent ont
l'impression que la question elle a été
traitée en principe de langue de bois ça
c'est le premier point c'est vraiment
les chiffres
sont pas très encourageants dans ce
cadre là
parce qu'on est post covid on est un an
après le covid et les chiffres sont
encore pire que pendant
le nombre de professionnels rapportés à
la je crois qu'on a une vraie expression
c'est pas une micro-expression mais une
vraie expression tout court de surprise
limite de peur je vais juste la remettre
ça c'est le premier point visiblement
les chiffres quand Hugo commence à
couper Macron là vous voyez la crise
passion de la mâchoire les les lèvres
qui se resserre avec une petite
écarquillement des yeux ça c'est pas de
la peur c'est pas de la surprise c'est
une forme de colère le dis bah qu'il est
en colère contre Go mais c'est une forme
de me faire couper là je l'ai même pas
eu passé
là vous avez vu l'écart qu'il manque à
augmenter et au lieu de serrer l'élève
maintenant il est dessert les ouvre un
petit peu tu as un petit mélange de peur
et de surprise à ce moment-là avec un
regard qui part sur le côté où il y a un
vrai besoin d'introspection de utiliser
je réponds quoi là à ça parce que c'est
pas prévu je viens de dire l'inverse en
fait c'était très pertinent du coup de
la part du et d'ailleurs je vois un
petit peu de satisfaction sur le visage
d'Hugo que j'avais pas regardé je pense
qu'il est au fond de lui c'est dire
c'est bien je lâche rien quoi et là on
est sur la fin des tonnements avec le
petit mouvement de tête d'Emmanuel
Macron de en fait le discours intéresse
et
après il va se reprendre évidemment mes
postes on est un an après le covid et
les chiffres sont encore pire que
pendant
mon cas mais non santé publique un petit
pléonasme inversé il dit non non j'ai
pas les mêmes chiffres moi son corps dit
oui certaine dit non alors bon c'est pas
ce qu'elle avait été là-dedans mais ça
montre qu'il y a une vraie confusion
mentale qui a fait c'est une technique
d'hypnose qui lui a fait Hugo
décryptiens on appelle ça la confusion
mentale souvent les hypnotiseurs font ça
les donneurs de spectacle je parle un
fond ça pour essayer de perturber le
cerveau de l'autre Hugo a perturbé
maniel Macron petite médaille taux de
tentative de des noms de tentatives de
suicide le point après c'est qu'il faut
regarder comment on dit le système qu'on
vient de mettre en place sont efficace
ou pas par rapport à ça
donc après mais quand il fait son
explication pour reprendre il se relève
et écouter l'intonation de la voix je
sais même pas de quoi il parle la
précisément à ce moment-là mais
l'intonation de la voix de la gestuelle
et le comportement c'est un peu comme on
vous reproche un truc que vous avez fait
un petit mensonge sur quelque chose tu
vois tu es rentré tard et puis mais tu
n'es pas rentrer à 20h et tu es rentré à
22h et toi tu dois te justifier à ce
moment-là tu veux pas trop mentir mais
tu veux t'en sortir et pas dire vraiment
ce qui s'est passé non mais c'est pas ça
mais je t'avais dit j'avais du travail
et du coup en fait c'est un peu duré je
suis rentré et il a les mêmes
intonations la même gestuelle que la
personne qui se justifie en cherchant
une justification crédible qui soit pas
forcément dans le mensonge mais qui s'en
sortent et surtout qu'on lui qu'on ne
creuse pas en fait c'est fait pour
mettre une barrière combien de pas
encore creuser dans les questions et
quand il sent que ça c'est réglé et
récupère sa position de base qui est
plus avachie dans le soulagement on le
voit sur le screen que je viens de faire
là sur le pose plus que dans l'écoute
tout à l'heure où le menton et avancé là
c'est quand même dans le soulagement
replié sur lui-même tout ça c'est un
travail inconscient de c'est bon je m'en
suis sorti quoi c'est que notre
électrique comme je le disais avec
l'énergie
on fait de l'électricité avec du charbon
c'est pas le cacher nous et justement
très bon exemple si vous le permettez
assez rare pour être signalé 1942 là
c'est un vrai sourire alors un peu
crispé mais on a un vrai sourire
d'Emmanuel Macron comme s'il y avait une
vraie complicité avec Hugo à ce
moment-là il y a de la crispation un peu
carnassière en bas quand même mais il se
sent pas en danger par cette coupure
parce que parce que je pense qu'ils
doivent être raccords dans ce qu'il
raconte mais on a un vrai sourire de on
a la commission alors qu'on voulait
détecter un sourire vous cachez aussi le
bas du visage et vous voyez si l'œil est
rigueur en fait ça vous évite de devoir
détailler tous les muscles et tous les
plis de l'oeil son copain sont devenus
du copain au moins l'espace d'une
seconde que le aujourd'hui il y a un
avantage fiscal pour les acteurs de
l'aviation il y a même la France taxe
plus que beaucoup d'autres voisins sont
son aviation derrière ça comment on
explique qu'on termine avec un billet de
train juste avant là qui pose sa
question Hugo on voyait tous les signes
d'agacement il avait je pense toute la
liste contradictoire en tête là et on le
voit c'est un moment où il est plus en
train de sourire parce que dans ces
échanges souvent Hugo a un léger sourire
non pas de complaisance mais de
sympathie de l'échange là il a le menton
relevé il a les yeux mi-clos il envoie
son squelette je sais pas encore ce
qu'il va dire mais on le voit dans la
poste que je viens de faire il est
attaquant il est contradicteur il est
plutôt sûr de lui je défends un système
inefficace mais je suis pour l'écologie
non donc moi je suis cohérent
mais je dis beaucoup de commentaires
moi je suis cohérent le système
l'aviation là c'est un enjeu mêler un
agacement pour Emmanuel Macron il a
changé de position et il s'est même
replacé on en est là c'est un agacement
parce que il veut faire passer son
message non pas à nous là mais il veut
convaincre Hugo et c'est intéressant
comme comportement parce que j'ai jamais
vu Emmanuel Macron ou vouloir convaincre
les journalistes quand il est au plateau
TF1 au plateau de France 2 ou autre
chose là le fait qu'il se repositionne
physiquement par rapport à Hugo montre
qu'il essaie de convaincre Hugo parce
qu'il a vu qu'il l'avait perdu et on le
voit dans l'attitude d'Hugo et dans ces
regards la juste quelques secondes avant
Léa je suis pas d'accord et c'est pas ce
que je suis en train de dire moi en plus
d'ailleurs celle le verbalisent moi j'ai
jamais dit ça et je parle de ça ça et du
coup Emmanuel Macron fait un petit
combat personnel de il faut que j'arrive
à le convaincre lui je pense que
inconsciemment il y a 6 jours qu'on va
Hugo je convaincre le reste de la
jeunesse en France peut-être peut-être
c'est ça qui se trame pour lui comme en
jeu mais c'est marrant de le voir
vouloir convaincre une personne alors
que d'habitude sur les interviews ou des
allocutions et cherche à convaincre dans
le fond ce qui écoutent l'acteur
français qui Air France il a été
concurrencé par beaucoup de locaux et
vous avez vu on a juste en amorce comme
Emmanuel Macron vient de se
repositionner et donc de prendre du lead
parce qu'il prend de la présence et plus
d'espace Hugo sert assis et
séropositionner aussi pourquoi il y a ce
différentiel parce que du côté du
ferroviaire il y avait beaucoup moins de
concurrence et un acteur qui était pas
assez efficace on a fait la réforme de
la SNCF on est plus efficace on a des
cheminots qui sont formidablement
engagés dans la transition on va aller
vers du mieux en mieux on investit sur
les infrastructures
il fait un ping-pong le bien le mal on a
fait ci on a fait ça on peut mettre une
petite musique de danse dessus je sais
pas si le frein mais il y a un petit
côté
à gauche à droite et il énumère comme ça
en binaire 2018 on réinvesti massivement
en parallèle on a encore du boulot là
dessus ça c'est la responsabilité
avec une petite crise passion haute voix
les il est plutôt fort Hugo pour pas
couper l'intérieur mais en gardant sa to
do list en tête contradictoire je pense
que là il va il va rebalancer des
arguments il essayait de les contenir
comme ça à un moment donné tout à
l'heure aussi je me suis pas arrêté
dessus mais il se cachait la bouche
alors on dit je reprends avec des
pincettes qu'on se retient parler qu'on
a quelque chose à dire qu'on etc et je
pense que c'était le cas qui sont
parfois moins cher et qui arrivent sur
notre réseau et qui rendent le train
attractif je voudrais juste ajouter un
point essayer donc en fait c'est pour ça
qu'il avait ça depuis tout à l'heure
c'était pour commencer à positionner sa
main et essayer de couper il va essayer
de le faire bah c'est normal en fait
qu'il essaie maintenant parce que comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure plus la
réponse va être longue plus elle va être
multipoint plus on a la sensation
d'avoir répondu mais surtout plus ça va
être compliqué de revenir point par
point sur tout ce qui a été dit sans
ralentir tous les points qui doivent
être encore vus dans l'interview et
c'est ça aussi le talent de la langue de
bois politique que ce soit pour noyer le
poisson ou pour répondre à côté ou pour
répondre vrai ça j'en sais rien encore
une fois c'est pas mon travail plus la
réponse est longue des multipliée dans
des points et elle part d'un des
directions plus les contradictions sont
longues si on veut redémonter chacun des
points par un c'est presque le double du
temps qu'il faudrait par rapport à ce
qui a été dit et qui va encore engendrer
de la réponse je remets juste avant
parce qu'on voit Hugo faire sa tentative
Emmanuel Macron qu'a un bon pouvoir
parce que en plus comme il est
argumentatif on peut pas lui refuser de
faire sa conclusion en entier et Hugo
qui va juste avoir vous allez devoir
parce qu'on ne voit que de côté la
crispation de mâchoire de et qui sur
notre réseau et qui rend le train
attractif tentative il approche de la
lucarne je voudrais juste ajouter un
point ballon bloqué et juste là
c'est bon et il a même je l'ai pas je
l'avais même pas chopé pose la main sur
la jambe du coup pour contrôler sa main
je parle du GO et il a la jambe qui se
met à boucher aussi c'est que là il est
rempli de nerf quoi de papa de pâte
agressivité mais il y a tout ce qu'il a
en tête qui a envie de sortir
est-ce que réellement pour des raisons
économiques on doit continuer à
encourager une industrie qui de fait
pollue infiniment plus que d'autres
modes de prix fort c'est ce qu'on fait
pour toutes les industries d'abord nous
dans notre usage qu'est-ce qu'on va tous
faire et ça c'est ça la transition 1 on
va se poser des questions qu'on ne se
posait pas avant il reprend il reprend
le compte c'est les comportements parce
que les questions du goût sont trop
précises d'économie d'énergie la
question du coup
une manière d'être posée qu'elle limpide
qui permet de répondre précisément
quelque chose de précisément quelque
chose de négatif ou précisément on ne
sait pas encore on est en train de
chercher et comme les trois solutions
sont pas envisageables par le président
il garde sa posture autant pas ça
posture basse qu'il avait précédemment
et il revient au point par point pour
retrouver de la longueur qu'est-ce que
c'est dans ce cas une bonne tenue pour
aller à l'école parce que alors ça c'est
pas de président de la République qui
disent qu'il y a une bonne tenue
effectivement
mais je réagissais là un problème de
société là pour le coup sur la laïcité
c'est le président de la République qui
en est le garant et donc je renvoie là
pour bien qu'il y a des zones mais non
mais non c'est des recueil il y a des
déclarations du coup qui reviennent oui
mais si vous laissez pour ça que moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose que ce
soit au niveau de l'établissement vous
avez des établissements c'est un sujet
très sensible qui est attaqué et c'est
assez marrant de voir la stratégie
d'Emmanuel Macron la stratégie digne du
confident il a jamais été aussi bas et
c'est pas pour faire preuve d'humilité
c'est pas parce qu'il est gêné par la
question c'est qui veut engager en fait
la conversation sur un terrain de la
confidence et non pas de la
confrontation et on l'a avec la prosonie
il a baissé sa voix il a baissé son
rythme entre guillemets en train de
chuchoter c'est pas le cas au sens
littéral mais vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il va commencer à parler comme ça
alors on va discuter un petit peu de ça
c'est pas si simple quand même et pardon
mais ça a parfois donné le pire on peut
pas faire comme s'il y avait pas eu la
tact terroriste et l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty dans notre pays et ça c'est
fait là on parle on parle de la Baya on
ne parle pas de mais je ne fais aucun
mais je dis juste ce système est là
alors là c'est argumentatif c'est dans
le verbal il y a eu un parallèle qui a
été fait avec le terrorisme que Hugo n'a
pas laissé passer qu'est-ce qu'il a pris
confiance en Lui Hugo là on le voit dans
sa position oui mais là on parle pas de
ça on parle juste de la Bahia et il
renvoie en fait un truc qui était pas un
argument qui était même pas une vraie
comparaison d'ailleurs entre la bagarre
ou le terrorisme parce que ça aurait été
très mal venu mais le fait de les mettre
dans la même phrase ça veut quand même
essayer de les marier dans la conscient
collective et Hugo le ballet directement
et Emmanuel Macron est obligé de
recomposer avec Emmanuel Macron à face à
lui quand même quelqu'un qui gère un
débat et là on parle on parle de la
Bayard on ne parle pas de mais je ne
fais aucun mais je dis juste ce système
est là et ça c'est fait parce qu'un
ancien la réponse quand même d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est non je ne dis aucun je dis
juste enfin ce système est là et oui
parce qu'il peut pas puisque du coup
c'est vraiment très mal venu de marier
les deux c'était vraiment une stratégie
c'est un peu manipulatoire on va pas se
mentir de de mettre le terrorisme et la
bailleur dans la même phrase et du coup
quand Hugo lui fait remarquer il a sa
vraie gêne de il peut pas dire non non
je fais aucun parallèle entre les deux
parce que il veut qu'il y en ait un
kinest mais il peut pas dire oui il y a
un parallèle entre les deux parce que ça
ça va poser des gros problèmes pour pour
le président de la République donc c'est
devenu non je dis pas c'est parce que je
dis un bon et hein allez bubble ta
question on va prendre la mienne donc on
va pas rentrer dans ce débat là parce
que là-bas est réellement forcément la
façon dont vous le voyez ici c'est un
parallèle qui est je pense fait beaucoup
elle peut faire
aucun parallèle moi le parallèle entre
la Baya et et l'assassinat de Samira
il revient dessus j'ai pas le visage de
Macron mais je pense vraiment qu'il est
dégoûté parce qu'il est obligé de dire
non je ne fais aucun parallèle c'est
incroyable je vous dis juste que la
question de la laïcité dans notre école
est une question profonde et que est-ce
que je l'ai mise en avant en vous
parlant de l'école non je pense que
l'école est un sujet non il est très
embêté Emmanuel Macron parce que Hugo
décrite n'a pas lâché le morceau et du
coup il s'est remis en position il a
augmenté le ton de sa voix mais ralenti
le rythme en mettant des cassures pour
être sûr de peser chacun de ces mots et
ce bras-là juste devant qui bouge c'est
pas pour asséner des choses c'est pour
protéger c'est une sorte de bouclier en
fait c'est le boxeur qui part comme ça
tous les coups qui peuvent venir il
essaye de reprendre le contrôle ça
devient un peu glisser des mains
aujourd'hui vous avez une minorité de
gens vous l'avez très bien dit
et là il alterne vraiment ces choses-là
avec des vous l'avez très bien dit en
mode regardez vous n'avez pas besoin de
reprendre la parole parce que je dis que
je suis d'accord avec vous sur ces
points et donc il alterne ça avec la
main aussi qui fait ça sous prétexte de
dire vous l'avez très bien dit en même
temps il y a je te bloque si jamais tu
veux dire quelque chose c'est
littéralement ce geste là c'est
totalement ils ont des pénalités s'ils
le font pas et donc c'est une annonce
importante qu'on fait bizarre de lui
faire un clin d'oeil de mie conscient
faut je le vois de plus près
j'ai cru que c'était un clin d'oeil en
fait il a un œil faible donc là c'est
l'oeil droit qui se trouve plus
lentement que la ligne gauche mais
c'était les deux yeux en même temps et
par contre c'était un je pense une vraie
satisfaction et pas trop de crispation
en bas c'est une vraie satisfaction de
on est d'accord sur le même sujet et tu
as vu on a fait ce qu'il faut quoi après
on peut débattre de la méthodologie
encore une fois on traite pas de du fond
mais que de la forme mais j'ai cru qu'il
y avait fait vraiment un petit clin
d'oeil à la fin mais non c'est vraiment
un truc un peu comme ça quoi complément
de salaire en échange de certaines
missions qui viendraient qui viendraient
faire ça implique donc de signer très
sympa de le servir de l'eau à Hugo pas
sûr de l'avoir déjà vu servir de l'eau à
quelqu'un d'autre dans une autre
émission vous me direz les les verres
sont apportés par le reste des équipes
mais c'est très sympathique ça montre le
moment off mais on peut aussi y porter
un regard de technique de manipulation
et à dire que il sert Hugo décrypte en
premier et après il se sert et quoi
qu'il arrive en tout cas il offre ce
service à Hugo en manipulation on
appelle ça la technique de la
redevabilité puisque j'ai été sympa avec
toi bah tu dois être sympa avec moi tu
me dois quelque chose c'est la
réciprocité plutôt que c'est le principe
de réciprocité et la deuxième chose
c'est l'acceptation par l'autre fait
changer l'état d'esprit de l'autre
vis-à-vis de sol je vous explique si
vous demandez quelque chose un service
très simple à une autre personne et
qu'elle vous rend ce service très simple
parce que c'est vraiment simple
passe-moi le sel que elle va le faire
intérieurement cette personne va vous
rehausser dans sa base j'aime bien la
personne pour ne pas rentrer en
dissonance cognitive puisque j'ai
accepté de l'aider donc forcément j'ai
pas de vrais problèmes avec cette
personne là le verre d'eau Hugo l'a
accepté donc c'est un cadeau qui lui
fait il l'a accepté et les mêmes obligé
de remercier donc ça veut dire que quoi
qu'il arrive il doit avoir une opinion
positive de la personne en face de lui
est-ce que tout ça est calculé ou pas je
n'en sais rien dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires si ça avait
dû être calculé et ben ça aurait été
fait exactement comme ça et en milieu de
l'interview ça aurait été parfait comme
placement donc si c'est un hasard il est
bien quand même mais si on a chaque
génération qui tourne son arme ils vont
nous aider à aller à notre milliard de
reboisement c'est hyper important pour
la Sainte Catherine ensuite je continue
donc inversera la courbe des émissions
que vous avez fait ça mais rien mais pas
plus que ce que vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure surprendre moins d'avion les
avions un peu plus que un arbre c'est
tous ces gestes ce que je vous ai dit
sur l'avion plus j'évite un vol inutile
plus en effet je reboise pardon comme
vous l'avez dit il y a des choses qui
ont plus d'impact que d'autres questions
de la République non c'est pas ce que
j'ai mais là c'est les sentiments j'ai
le droit et elle a autant de gueule que
celle de celle des copains je suis
scientifique mais en l'occurrence mais
non mais moi aussi c'est les
scientifiques il faut reboiser oui et
donc
c'est marrant parce que Emmanuel Macron
avait essayé d'éviter la coupure et il a
compris comment fonctionner Hugo
décrypte d'où le jeu continue avant même
que Hugo décrypte a commencé à bouger
une oreille ce qu'il a pas empêché
d'intervenir et après c'est assez joyeux
vous avez vu comme comme débat entre
entre Hugo qui dit les arbres pas autant
qu'autre chose Emmanuel Macron moi aussi
j'ai le droit à ma part quand même
pourquoi ce serait moins important mon
truc c'est presque enfantin les
attitudes les intonations d'ailleurs
sont enfantines j'ai pas besoin de
rentrer dans le détail pour que vous
puissiez le voir et c'est assez rigolo
parce qu'après ça se conclue il reprend
décrochant le regard là exactement le
screen où on est du goût des crêpes qui
est encore souriant il y a un vrai jeu
de de non-up c'est à dire que Hugo
descript qui dit on sait on sait très
bien et vous savez vous-même et lui qui
verbalise du nom me dit fait oui mais
bon quand même on peut rigoler on a le
droit et Hugo qui était une souris parce
que il assiste à au fait qu'en vrai il
valide que c'est moins important donc
c'est assez rigolo on a passé une strat
ou même dans tout le non-verbal les deux
sont OK sur le fait que c'est un peu de
la poudre aux yeux mais juste il va pas
le verbaliser il va reprendre la suite
c'est incroyable on suivra tout ça dans
les dans les prochains jours ça va faire
quasiment deux heures qu'on deux heures
c'est pas mal hein et encore ils sont
deux alors pourquoi parce que juste
avant d'attaquer la suite je prends deux
secondes quand même pour bien vous dire
que de la tornade mon spectacle elle
repart sur les routes donc je vais être
principalement en tournée de gens juin
2024 mais j'ai quand même quelques
représentations de septembre à décembre
là vous avez toutes les villes qui
s'affichent il y aura pas d'autres
villes puisque ça se prépare un an à
l'avance une tournée vous avez les liens
dans la description là vous voyez aussi
quelques images du spectacle des
extraits du spectacle c'est ce que ça
donne sur scène sauf que ça va être
nouvelle version et un écran géant
derrière moi une nouvelle scénographie
un nouveau tour c'est un mélange de
mentalistes d'humour de science aussi
ces deux heures d'interactivité avec
vous je reste à la fin des spectacles
quand c'est possible quand on enchaîne
pas avec notre ville de lendemain bref
j'ai hâte de vous voir si vous avez pas
vu archétype c'est maintenant parce que
je pense pas qu'il y aura une troisième
tournée ça risque d'être la dernière
tournée de ce spectacle où il y a toute
une partie comme ça de décryptage mais
il y a d'autres trucs qui sont très fun
qui sont sur le cerveau où j'essaie
aussi de savoir ben en fait qui vous
êtes de vous décrypter vous des
personnes qui montent sur scène ce sera
peut-être vous également et d'autres
surprises sur le cerveau je vous en dis
pas plus mais vous avez le lien dans la
description j'espère vous y retrouver
faut pas oublier les aussi qui ont été
revalorisés 3,5% ce qui avait une baisse
en début de quinquennat 5 euros qui
avait été prise en truc on a fait plus
que les rattrapés et là la
revalorisation n'a que
c'était trop marrant j'ai juste un micro
point parce que j'avais oublié tout ça
je recherche Macron vient rajouter pour
lui un argument Fortis
il y avait une baisse en début de
quinquennat qui est balayé tout de suite
par Hugo décrypte et là on a le
changement de comportement qui est ah
non non là c'est pas possible en fait
c'est vraiment l'attitude de quelqu'un
qui est saoulé quand quand il est
rechange complètement de comportement
là c'est pas possible et en même temps
pourquoi il est en mode saoulé c'est
parce que ça vient aussi du fait je dis
ça parce qu'il a du compulser son
dossier il le maîtrise pas bien donc il
va pas pouvoir réargumenter dans toutes
les pistes parce que si ça se trouve
Hugo maîtrise mieux le sujet que lui qui
a essayé d'en faire un argument là 5
euros qui avait été prise un truc on a
fait plus que les rattraper et là la
revalorisation n'a que
de fin c'est pas un gros argument donc
je ne sais qui n'ont pas eux quoi c'est
pareil quoi nous que je n'ai en plus de
ça blague à part alors là ça a été fait
forcément spontanément et inconsciemment
mais Hugo a parlé en pourcentage et
Emmanuel Macron a parlé en quantité en
chiffres et ben c'est assez malin parce
que ça peut pas se comparer en fait on
sait pas de quelle valeur on parle on
peut on sait pas vraiment nous de
l'autre côté est-ce que ça a été
rattrapé ou pas puisque ces deux
chiffres my côte à côte ne veulent rien
dire ces deux unités différentes la
baisse vaut nettement nettement moins
que la suppression de la sécurité
sociale étudiante que j'évoquais mais là
je rappelais ça va en plus du reste oui
l'engagement l'engagement sera tenu et
sur les protections hygiéniques et donc
après il se reprend un tout petit peu
sur un ton bas parce qu'il est moins sûr
et après le referme en reprenant son
temps haut et en repartant de l'autre
côté merci encore monsieur le Président
pour merci entre-temps merci à vous pour
votre confiance merci à toute l'équipe
aussi qui est derrière cette on termine
avec un Emmanuel Macron qui a repris sa
position de départ donc il doit pas être
insatisfait un Hugo qui a pris beaucoup
de confiance avec le temps et qui est
très satisfait aussi et puis à Fabien
qui est assez satisfait d'avoir fait
l'analyse assez rapidement et un Loïc
qui doit être satisfait d'avoir fait le
montage rapidement aussi pour vous
produire la vidéo et Virginie qui doit
être satisfaite d'avoir sélectionné le
passage pour qu'on puisse travailler
vite merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
j'espère vraiment vous voir en spectacle
venez on se rend compte dans la vraie
vie à très bientôt Ciao